♪ Start of my life was kinda rough ♪
♪ I had an up hill battle ♪
♪ The doctor said my pair was down ♪
♪ And said my life was fragile ♪
♪ Respect is for the game ♪
♪ And GaryVee the name ♪
♪ Just put your head and do the work ♪
♪ And everything will change ♪
♪ Sip the tea, help the feels ♪
♪ Yeah, that's what I wanted ♪
♪ Being patient hella tricky ♪
♪ Yet I'm being honest ♪
♪ Tea with GaryVee ♪
♪ Put your positivity ♪
- What's good, everybody.
Good morning, here on
Friday, the 29th of May.
I missed all of you.
I hope you missed me as much as I did.
It's good to be back on Tea with GaryVee.
Jen Halston, thank you so
much for being on, Scott.
Thank you for being on, Peter McDonald.
Please leave your comments right now.
Facebook, YouTube, Twitter, LinkedIn,
where are you from?
I like getting a sense.
Twitch in the building.
James Michael, Pullo
great to see you here,
Thank you so much.
Jorge, Christina, thank you so much.
William Kayden in the
building, Garett Glenn.
I'm trying to have my
TikTok off the chain.
Hope everybody's super, super, super well.
Dustin, how are you?
- Excellent, missed you.
- Missed you too bro, missed you too.
And it's really, really,
really good to be here.
- Awesome.
- It's really good to be here.
- Today's gonna be a good
show, very good show.
I already know it.
- I agree.
I think today will be
a very, very good show,
let's start it off.
- Cool.
- Oh, we're starting it off hot!
What's good Boat.
- What's up boss?
- How're you Yachty?
- I'm living, I ain't been to sleep yet.
- Is that a beautiful Bape shirt?
- Yeah, man, I had to stay up for you.
- Because the album, huh?
- No, this is for you.
If I went to sleep, I won't have made it.
- I get that.
But what about the album, bro?
- Oh yeah, man.
That was midnight man, it was amazing.
- How's the feedback been?
- Great.
- I can't wait to sit down
and listen to it tonight,
- Man, it was great.
- You're getting some real love.
- Yeah, I am.
Genuinely it's dope.
- I love that.
So what's been going
on, how are you feeling?
- Good bro.
You know, I'm home, I
recently bought a house.
I'm moving into a new house next Friday.
- Congratulations.
- Thank you.
And I'm...
- What was the biggest process with
this new album?
Like how'd you think about the project?
- The hardest part was when I had to
strip songs.
You know, I had got towards
the end of the process
and I had too many,
and then just trying to
figure out what to keep and...
- But why are there too many?
Like will the record labels,
do they just like...
If you were like, no, I
really want all these on
or is that your own,
"I just don't wanna
have that many on this"?
- Yeah, I mean, of course I
could do whatever I wanna do,
but in a sense, I don't
wanna have a 26 long album,
26 song album.
- Why?
- I just don't.
- You don't like 26?
- I just don't wanna have
a hour and 20 minute album.
- I get that.
I want an hour and 20
minutes of your voice.
- Well, I mean
- In your stories.
- No, you have a number
you can call me anytime.
(laughs)
- But what's going on with your TikTok?
- It's going crazy.
I just started a week ago.
- What have I been telling you?
- Yeah, TikTok is it.
- Listen, it's a huge opportunity for you.
You have to have to, have to
make sure as much of the music
on the album is going to be on there.
- Yeah.
- Like literally make a TikTok
for like your favorite hook,
or verse, or bar
in every song,
you need to make a video around that clip.
- Yeah.
- 100%
- For sure.
- I'll talk to you over
the weekend for sure.
You got any questions
before you go to sleep?
- No, you're the man obviously,
and the whole world knows that
and man just keep doing you.
I have nothing to say.
- What's the name of the new album?
I wanna make sure everybody
in the Vayner Nation
who's watching right now, goes to Spotify,
- Lil Boat 3, man is everywhere.
iTunes, Spotify, title, Google
play, Amazon, everything.
- Yeah, I can't wait to
listen to it, bro, I love you.
Thanks for staying it up,
- Love you, bro.
I wanted to give you some
love this morning, take care.
All right, everybody that is Lil Yachty.
One of the, one of the
funniest, most creative,
like such a deep thinker for a young man.
Real good kid, makes me
smile every time I see him,
so it's good to see him.
That's a nice little start to the show.
All right, let's get right
into it, let's keep it going.
- Hey GaryVee?
Hey Vivian, how are you?
- I'm great, how are you?
- I'm super well, real quick
Viv before we go into this.
- Yeah.
- Couple of things everyone,
today is the youngster's show
so we have a ton of
youngsters on today's show,
which I'm really excited about.
Dustin, am I doing a good
job with holding this up?
Like are you feeling happy about that?
- Yeah, it sounds great.
- Good.
So it's a youngster's show today.
Also, I'm gonna be thanking random people
on the show today for
entering the All In challenge.
So just a really fun, loving show.
We started off with Yachty.
His new album is out, "Lil Boat 3."
Make sure you download that, check it out.
I guarantee you're gonna love it.
There's a couple of Easter eggs
for the Vayner nation in there.
On a separate note,
#teawithgaryvee.
I wanna make sure that everybody
hits Twitter hard right
now with this hashtag.
I wanna do more of this
'cause I want more awareness
for the show, we wanna do more
good vibes, more positivity.
#teawithgaryvee, leave
your favorite quotes
or your favorite moments
from each guest today,
and I'll go and share and
retweet a bunch of you.
So there's the hashtag.
Viv what's cooking.
Where are you from?
What's your story?
- I'm 16 years old.
I'm from Connecticut.
And I'm about to be a senior.
And pretty much my issue is
there's so many things
that I'm passionate about
and that I love, but I guess...
I'm an athlete, I'm into
modeling, I sell bracelets,
but I guess my question is,
how do I make the right decision
on what to focus on or what to pursue?
- Well, can I give you great news?
- Yeah.
- Whatever you pursue,
whether it's all of them,
which is absolutely feasible
at this young of an age
up until, you know, for the next 16 years,
you've only been alive for 16.
And for the next 16 years,
if you just pursue all three,
that would be smart
because you'd only be 32
and you'd have a sense of your skill
and your love for those three things.
But let me tell it to you in a better way.
Here's some good news.
You won't even know, you won't even know
if one of them was the better decision,
'cause that's not how life works.
Everyone's so crippled to
make the right decision,
when you'll never know,
there is no time machines.
There is no preview machines.
You just pick and go, you go
with what you feel at the time.
It's more about loving yourself
and being confident in yourself.
You just don't know, you don't know.
- Yeah, it's just hard because
I'm so used to having a plan.
Like I'm so organized and I
like things laid out, you know,
and I know where I wanna be,
but it's just like, which
path do I take to get there?
It's just hard.
- I totally understand
but like, so lay it out,
go bring out your journal and say,
I'm in a model and retail, an athlete
for the next three years,
then I'm gonna pick one
and go hard for three years
then I'm gonna make a decision at 22
if I wanna change it up,
I'm telling you, life is fluid, right?
I bet you in your planned out process,
you didn't have a pandemic
keeping you in the house
for six months, right?
- Yeah
- Like, you know life,
It's nice that you have
things planned out,
but you have to start the
process of being prepared
for when life takes turns.
- Yeah, it's just like...
- There is no wrong choice Viv.
- Mm-hmm, yeah, but it's
like, what, how do I...
But the thing is, there's more
than three things on my mind,
you know?
- So do those fucking things.
- But how do I know
which ones I have been?
Which one is it?
Which one's the one?
- You're not gonna know.
- Damn.
(laughs)
- That's what you gotta
get comfortable with.
- Mm-hmm,
damn.
- Yeah, it is damn, it's good.
It's actually good, right now it's damn.
But if you keep working on this,
you re-watch this video 4,000 times,
you play it in your own head,
you've figured out for your own way,
it's actually amazing because
then there's no wrong answer.
- Yeah.
- Everyone's like, I want the answer.
I'm like, no, because then
there's wrong answers.
How about not having
wrong answers or answers
and just living and just
aiming for happiness.
And if you pursue modeling for seven years
and then at 23, you're like, nah,
and then you want to sell coconuts, go.
- Yeah.
- You need to, Viv you
need to make sure that
you want the plan, not your
parents, your teachers, society,
your coaches, you know what I mean?
They want plans, 'cause they,
you know, that's what...
Most people play defense,
but the 30s and 40s and 50s
and 60 year olds that try to
make 16 year olds live life
like they're 30, 40, 50,
60 are doing a disservice.
- Yeah, I wanna be ahead of the game,
you know, I...
- You are ahead of the game,
Viv, if you're on
fucking Tea with GaryVee,
you're ahead of the fucking game.
(laughs)
- I know.
- I'm serious though.
- I've watched so many
of these and I'm like,
I could have never
imagined myself being here.
So I don't know
- Honestly you are, listen,
the way to be ahead of the game
is to be focused on happiness,
not perceived societal success,
or money or clout
or whatever else is
running through your head.
- You wanna actually be,
let me teach you something
you'll never forget.
You wanna be ahead of the game,
6aim for fucking happiness.
- I'm happy every day,
I only do what makes me happy,
but the thing is a lot
of things make me happy
and I'm happy with a lot of things so,
- Me too, me too.
Basically you're talking
about me right now.
(laughs)
- Oh my gosh, you did not
just compare yourself to me.
(laughs)
- Yes, I did.
- That's crazy but um...
- Listen to me, stay in
that zone, that's good.
Don't let people talk you out of that
and saying you gotta focus on something
or you gotta be practical
or you gotta get real
or you've gotta figure
it out at a certain point
'cause you're gonna be a senior.
Like, it's crazy you're a fucking child.
I know 60 year olds that
don't have a fucking idea
about life.
- Yeah, let's just,
well, I just feel like,
but I just wanna make the
most of all my time, you know.
- Let me promise you the best
way to make use of your time,
by not dwelling about making
the most use of your time
by not overthinking, by not like debating
by not, you know, like the
way to make most of your time
is by doing shit.
- Yeah.
So like, I'm just a bad
decision maker though.
I'm not like not a bad decision maker but,
I just, I don't know how to
choose between certain things
and what I want more.
- Flip a fucking coin.
- Okay.
- Viv I'm serious, I'm serious,
you like them all, you
shouldn't be crippled
by having lots of interests.
- Yeah, yeah, all right.
I'll try Gary, I'll do it for you.
- All right, do it for
me, have a great day.
- I love you, man.
- I love you back, see ya.
- Bye.
- All right let's keep
this going, that was fun.
Jose, looks good.
Hi (mumbles) Gary
- How are you?
- I'm doing well.
- What's been going on.
- Not much, I'm just
super excited to be here.
Thanks for doing this.
- I'm happy to do it.
Tell me about yourself.
Where are you from?
What do you do?
- Yeah, so I'm from LA, California.
First-generation, just graduated
from Harvard last year.
I'm passionate about real
estate and cryptocurrency.
- Whoa!
Harvard huh?
You went subtle on that, man.
That's a big get, good for you.
You're a real fucking student out here.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, just
working hard you know.
- School came very natural to you?
- Yeah, I was able to catch
things pretty well in school.
But I think a lot of
it just comes down to,
hard work.
I don't think I was any more,
intelligent than anybody
else in my classroom.
I just noticed that,
I paid attention when
other people wanted to
just goof around.
- Yeah, I goofed around
like fucking crazy.
I didn't actually, I didn't good around,
I would've like bothered
you if I sat next to you
trying to sell you some shit.
And you'd be like,
"Shut the fuck up, Gary, I'm
trying to get to Harvard."
(laughs)
- That would've been us.
So what kind of kid were you like?
Like did you collect things?
Were you just all about
the books, sports, music?
Like how did you...
- well, so I grew up
from a low income family.
So when I started, I was like maybe,
I don't know, four or five.
And my mom kind of gave me these little
like plush toys to go and sell out to like
to my neighbors and stuff.
So I wanted a Nintendo DS.
So I went out and I sold those things.
Sold like 200 of them, bought my DS.
And I kinda just kept
that work ethic going.
For high school, yeah I really
did have to hit the books
because I wanted to get
into Harvard because,
they have really good
financial aid systems
and I didn't wanna pay
for any of my college.
So luckily I wasn't,
I actually came out of
college with savings, so yeah.
- The Harvard co-sign and savings?
That's just intense bro,
I'm really proud of you.
That's Epic.
- Yeah, yeah, thank you...
- Do you have any questions?
- Yeah I do so, I'm preparing for...
Basically I wanna start a company,
within maybe two or three years,
I know I just graduated from college
so like I know I need more,
- What's your social media handles?
- @joseintheflesh, that's my Instagram.
I don't really do TikTok but I should,
I know I should do that
based on what you were
saying to Little Boat.
- You should if you want the awareness
and the attention to deploy
against your nonprofit ventures,
your political ventures,
your social ventures,
your business ventures,
building audience, allows
you to have a voice.
And today you might not
care about anything,
but in 16 years you might,
or today you might be like,
"Well, I don't sell anything."
Yet you wanna raise money
to build a playground
in your neighborhood.
Well guess what, having 400,000 followers
on TikTok can do that.
I think people underestimate
what attention's value is.
I speak in the context of,
you know, business so much,
but there's so many reasons
to build an audience
because there's so much
opportunity out there
to really do things.
- Yeah, yeah that makes sense.
- Go ahead.
- So the question that I had is,
I'm pretty sure for
the initial year or two
that I start this company,
it'll probably be burning profit
for a little while.
So what is the best,
what is the most convincing
kind of prototype,
to minimize the risk for investors?
Because I know like I invest my money
and so like whenever I see or like read
a company's balance sheet
or any of their financial statements,
I want to, I wanna see what
the business is working like.
So what's the most convincing thing?
- The problem is when
you're on idea phase,
you're just throwing
numbers on Excel sheet
to appease financial people.
- Yeah.
- It's some Harvard shit.
- You know, like to me,
you gotta look at it one of two ways.
One, listen, I talk a lot about,
colleges are a why, if you
go into debt being an issue.
You on the flip side are
the reverse poster child,
you did it perfect in my opinion.
To have a Harvard co-sign
and not have financial debt,
Jesus, you like, to me, that's the,
you're kind of like the bizarro,
like all the things I tell kids, I'm like,
"Hey, do not get in school,
start your business,
"don't take on debt,
learn, work for free."
You've played the other
side of the coin perfectly.
So you've got leverage and you can go,
you can get meetings, cold, by saying,
I went to Harvard, here's my business,
and you can get meetings
and show a 16 page deck.
And you know what the answer is,
you don't even need me
for that affirmation.
You just got to show 'em a
projection of 2020 for profit.
That blows me away, that people
fuck with shit like that.
'Cause that's on some guessing shit,
but it works all day long.
Or you go to somebody
who's an entrepreneur
and just believes in you as a kid
and just wants to invest in you.
And they're a little bit more loose,
more intuitive, you
might be more analytical.
I'm more emotional.
I invest in people based on intuition.
- Yeah.
- You know what I mean?
- Tumblr's balance sheet didn't look good,
but I knew David Karp was a genius
and Tumblr was gonna win and it did.
- Yeah.
- Right and sold for a billion dollars.
You know what I mean?
So, I think there's a lot
of ways to do it Jose.
- Okay, gotcha.
So my initial round...
So what I wanted to show
basically as a prototype
was maybe buy a simple duplex.
And for background,
the company that I wanna
start is kind of relating,
like real estate
and are you familiar with
like smart contracts?
- Yes.
- So I kinda wanna mesh those two ideas
to give tenants more leverage
and at the same time, give
the landlord more leverage.
- I got it.
- So...
- If you're saying you've
saved up enough money
that you can go execute an
example, it's game over.
- Okay, yeah I'm saving up money.
Like that's partly why I'm
working on at this business.
- Yeah.
- Okay, cool so that was my...
- Stop, bro, bro, seeing it one time
is always better than
reading about it 10 times.
- Yeah.
- If you can show people the
fucking truth it's game over.
- Yeah.
- I invest in that kind of shit all day.
'Cause you're like, Oh, proof of concept?
- Yeah.
- Hustler kid, sold
fucking stuffed animals,
got his ass to Harvard from low income,
no debt?
Yeah, fucking, I'll go with this dude.
- Okay.
And then the other
question that I had was,
I'm obviously very new to all of this,
and you hear horror
stories, at Harvard about,
who knows if Mark Zuckerberg
actually stole Facebook or not,
you never know, so like how
do you protect your ideas,
as you going through (mumbles)?
- You can't, ideas are commodity.
You just give out your idea.
Bro, you just gave your idea.
- Yeah
- Bro you just gave your idea
to 20,000 people just now
and in a week, 400,000 are gonna watch it.
You just, you gave it.
That fucking bullshit story about Zack's,
that's just fucking horse shit.
You know, executions the game.
- Yeah.
- Facebook was fucking Myspace.
Myspace was Friendster.
Winklevoss is talking out here
like they invented some shit.
Get the fuck outta here.
(laughs)
- Okay.
- It's execution bro.
- Execution, okay, gotcha.
- Bro, I really appreciate you.
I know we have a lot
of mix of people today,
I really appreciate your...
- No problem.
- No, no, no, I just wanted
to appreciate you for
donating for the All In challenge,
I think, you bought some raffle
tickets for my thing, right?
- Yeah.
- I really appreciate that.
It's going to a good cause
and people are getting fed, you know?
- Yeah, yeah, of course yeah.
I also do stuff for like
Omaze and different things.
It's like, you never know when you can win
and it's helpful, you know?
- Have you ever won some shit?
- No, not from Omaze.
(laughs)
- Well listen, it's pretty crazy though,
because you did win some shit.
Yeah, yeah, I mean,
nobody has been very clear
with me over the phone.
I'm guessing that's what's
happening, but I'm not sure.
- You're guessing right Jose,
you fucking won the
GaryVee All In challenge.
You are the winner of my
year long fucking event.
- Awesome, hey I'm super happy.
- I'm about to spend the
next fucking year with you
motherfucker.
- That's sick, awesome.
- Congratulations bro, thank
you so much for entering,
Congratulations for winning.
You are the winner of
the GaryVee experience.
For everybody who's just joining,
if you don't know, Jose
stay on here right now.
Let's play the video to what
was the All In challenge win.
I am giving away the
ultimate GaryVee experience.
We'll garage saling and film trash-talk,
get a workout with me and Mike Vacanti
$25,000 shopping spree at Wine Library,
ultimate Jets experience,
guest of my podcast,
I'm gonna fly you to three of my keynotes,
the ultimate GaryVee experience.
- Yeah, no, it's...
(laughs)
- You ready?
- I'm super excited like...
- Dustin, that wasn't
even the whole thing,
what just happened, Dustin?
- I don't know, I thought
you wanted to keep it short.
- What part of like
"Show the whole thing."
Did you not understand Dustin?
with your fucking turquoise,
you got a fucking
turquoise fucking tank top
and you're not playing
the whole fucking thing?
- It's casual Friday.
- Casual Friday, get the fuck outta here.
Actually that's fine,
we'll play it at the end.
Jose, congratulations bro,
I'm looking forward to the Jets game.
You got $25,000 worth
of wine coming your way.
I don't know what you're
gonna do with that.
You might have to flip that.
I'm looking forward to the three times
I see you at the keynotes next year.
The time at Vayner media will,
I mean, look now you're really set.
When you come in to work
at Vayner for the week,
I'll lineup seven to 12
investment meetings for you
we'll get you a deck proper.
It's a fucking wrap, bro.
You fucking won.
- Okay, awesome, thanks man.
- You got it brother take care.
- See ya.
- I'll see you soon.
- You know what the problem
with somebody so calculated
and fucking epic as Jose,
his reaction was like,
"Thank you very much."
Like, we needed, Dust, I
think we made a mistake.
I think we need to pull
it from the drawing again.
I needed somebody to fucking cry.
I needed snot coming out of their mouth.
You know?
Like I needed real shit.
Jose was like,
"I appreciate that, I will
execute on my winning."
You know?
- I think I would probably
react the same way though.
I'll just be like in shock still
not knowing how to react.
- I love it, I love it, I love it.
Anyway, all right.
So, hey for everybody here,
thank you so much for
entering the All In challenge.
We raised over $500,000
or around $500,000 on my raffle alone.
And then obviously thank
you for all of you.
We raised $2.3 million
on TikTok the other day.
Let's keep getting into
the youngster's show.
My vibes are high now I'm feeling good.
Let's get this going.
- Hello?
- Hi, how are you my
man, what's your name?
- I'm Nafay.
- You're Nafay,
where are you from?
- Nafay, I'm from New Jersey.
- What part?
- Precip Ne.
- Very nice, close to where I grew up.
Awesome to meet you, what's good?
- Yes so I'm only like 11 years old,
so I'm like really
young as you always say.
- Yeah.
- So I've done like a lot of things,
I've done trading, I've had my
own drop shipping businesses
and I've got all those things,
but what I really want to become
is an actor.
But I'm really convinced
that to become an actor,
you gotta be in like
one of the big cities,
like Los Angeles or like
Orlando, like those big places,
but I'm all the way here in New Jersey,
and it's like really hard to move to
all the way across the
country all the way there.
So what's some advice
that you can help me with,
how can I become an actor
without like going to big places.
- So you're a youngster,
so I don't know if you're
gonna know all these names,
but do you know who Bruce Willis is?
- I don't think so, no.
- No worries, Joe Piscopo?
- No, I don't think so.
- No, Frank Vincent?
- I don't think so.
- No, right.
So look, the bottom line is
there's unlimited actors from New Jersey.
Do you know who Meryl Streep is?
- I don't think so.
- It's okay, it's okay if
you know none of these.
Jason Alexander from
Seinfeld, you know that dude?
- Maybe, I'm not sure if...
- Good news, don't worry, you
don't need to, you're only 11.
You know, that makes sense to me.
But do you know Danny
Devito is or John Travolta?
- Oh yeah.
- Good.
All of those people are from New Jersey.
You're 11, so I mean, do
you wanna act when you're 22
or do you wanna act now?
- I wanna act now.
- What, do you think your
parents are gonna let you
go to New York and do auditions?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Well, good news.
You don't need to go to fucking Orlando.
We got this.
- Yeah, yeah, that's good.
- Bro, you're in, we got this.
You just gotta get your parents
to drive you to New York
and do auditions,
literally google auditions in
New York for acting, right?
- Yeah.
- And go try out.
And here's the good part,
even if you stink at it now,
if you work at it for 11 years,
which is how long you've been alive,
at 22 you can go to LA
and you can try out for the next 10 years
and then ready for this
'cause it doesn't feel like this at 11.
If you do that for 10 years,
you'll still be young at 32.
You might get your acting break at 33,
and since you have this
entrepreneurial hustle
that's already in you,
you'll probably be able
to maintain your lifestyle
while you keep going out for acting,
you'll be able to do side
hustles to pay your rent and eat.
And if this is really your dream
and this is really in your soul,
then you just go.
- Yeah, thanks, thank you.
- You're welcome.
Does that make sense to you?
- Yeah I get it.
- Do you like, do you
understand that being in Jersey
is a great, being in New Jersey
is a lot better than
being in a lot of places.
'Cause you are moments,
I mean you're Piscataway,
you're 35, 40 minutes
away from New York city,
the epicenter of the world.
- Yeah, well, thank you.
- You're welcome.
New Jersey is better
than Orlando for acting.
- Thank you.
- You're welcome, have a great day.
- You too, thank you.
- You got it.
Dustin is your chat working?
Mine paused, I love the chat.
- It seems to be working.
- Okay.
- Absolutely.
- All right, keep going.
- Joe Piscopo
- Yep, Joe Piscopo.
- That kid knew zero, this
is what happens at 11.
- Yeah.
- You know, they don't
know any of these people.
That's what happens.
- Yeah I don't blame them.
- I don't blame them either.
Let's keep it moving.
Alex what's good?
- Hi Gary, I'm so excited
to finally talk to you.
- Thank you brother.
How are you, where are you from?
- I'm from Mexico and I'm 17.
- Very nice, real pleasure, what's good?
- Yeah, so basically I'm
really into business.
Like my goal is to build a company
and my dream is to live in Silicon Valley,
work 16 hours a day, coding,
just working then customer
acquisition, then marketing.
And right now, I'm debating
because last year I
started doing Amazon FBA,
to like have experience
and get some money,
- Yep
but it all kind of got
stuck because of Corona.
- And like last December I
started TikTok thanks to you,
I listened to one of your podcasts
and it was the first time
I've heard it from you.
So literally the first day I heard it,
I downloaded the app, I made a video,
it was about books I've read
and like, what are the lessons?
But it didn't work.
And I started consuming
more on the platform,
(laughs)
- Than making?
- Than making actually like
content native to the platform.
- When you said it wasn't working,
how many pieces did you post?
- Like 10, but it didn't work
because I posted in English
and I didn't know TikTok was original art.
So basically not a lot
of people understood it,
but now I changed it, and now
I'm at 1.7 million followers.
All thanks to you.
I'm glad I took your advice.
So my question is how...
First of all, I'm debating
whether I should go do college
because I'm always into learning,
I know it helps you be a better person.
- Of course.
Learning is amazing,
how you pay for learning
is what I want to debate.
- Yeah.
And I know I've been really
good at school, but it was not.
I just realized it was
because I'm really competitive
not because I particularly liked school.
Now that I think about it,
I didn't really liked it.
It's just that I wanted,
To beat everybody.
- to get better grades than my brother.
And you know, I like to
study computer science,
biotech and nanotechnology.
And I would like to talk to you about AI,
boys influencer at scale and CBR,
but that we'll have to wait, I think.
- All of that stuff is coming as you know,
that's why you brought it up
and you've obviously been listening.
So I appreciate that.
All of it it's coming,
all of it it's coming.
I would tell you learning how
to develop on top of Alexa
and Google home in voice
for this young of an age
is a huge opportunity.
- Yeah, so my question
is, should I go to college
or should I focus right now just on social
because I really like business.
- Remind me how it would be in Mexico.
Like, do you pay for college or no?
- Yes, but I would like to
go to a college in the US
I mean, my dream is to go to Stanford.
- Listen, if you can get to Stanford,
would you have to collect
debt to go to Stanford?
- Yeah, I think so.
Well, maybe I can side hustle,
you know, leverage my TikTok
- For sure, for sure
Listen, Stanford is one
of those few schools
that I think still has the
leverage with brand name
and the caliber of people
walking around on campus,
I think it's definitely one
that I am not against that
if you can get there, you know?
- Yeah, but that's the problem, see,
I know I could get there, but I would
have to focus all my time on it.
I wouldn't have time for anything else.
- That makes sense.
- You know, I wouldn't have
time to learn those skills
that I've learned on TikTok.
That's what I also started,
communicating my ideas
or leading content producing all of that.
And also...
- It's hard for me to tell you,
if you should or you shouldn't.
What I would tell you is,
I kinda think you're gonna
win either way to be frank.
Like if you ask me the truth
of what I'm thinking right now,
I'm thinking, well, this
kid's gonna win anyway.
So it's almost like which
one do you want more?
- You know, I really think about college
because of the environments actually,
like change your environment
so you can get connections
- But you can go somewhere
else without the college,
unless you're saying with immigration laws
and things of that nature,
that college is the way you can get in,
if you want it, that
would make sense to me.
- Okay.
- I don't know if you're
able to get into the US
without college and
just go to San Francisco
and hang out in coffee shops,
that would be my recommendation,
but if there is no way to do that,
I'm just not educated enough on where,
immigration laws are more importantly,
if you have family in the
US, things of that nature,
but if your way in is college,
then I think that's a worthwhile thought.
- Okay.
And last thing is that,
how can I leverage all the things
I've learned on TikTok,
you know, I've been
posting a lot on LinkedIn
on how to build your social
media, what I've learned.
And I've also helped people
which have contacted me
on how to build their TikTok.
- Charge them.
- I didn't charge them at that time
- I understand, in the
beginning that's fine,
But now I don't,
but now you have the leverage.
- Yeah, but I don't get that much like...
- Satisfaction?
- No, like, how to monetize because
on LinkedIn it's a whole
different audience,
I post on English which I
cannot leverage on my TikTok,
and I know going for the ask
is detrimental like on TikTok.
- Well, its not always detrimental.
Remember jab, jab, jab,
right hook, give, give, give.
I'm not scared to ask people right now
to sign up for wine text, watch this Alex,
sign up for wine text, today's
an insane $40 white wine
that's gonna be $18
and change right there.
I want every single person
to sign up for wine text.
Dustin, everybody who
signs up for wine text,
make sure you throw them on
the bottom screen right now.
If they just signed up and don't lie,
lying is the devil, the karma
will be horrible for you.
So, you know, I think you
can go in for the ask Alex.
If you make a TikTok right now saying,
"Hey, I've been able to grow my TikTok,
"I'm thinking about doing some consulting.
"If you're interested
message me on TikTok,"
all in Spanish and there's
people willing to pay you,
I think that's fine.
- Yeah.
Because the CPM on Mexico's it's slower
and you know, getting
brand deals it's harder
and thanks to Corona it's even harder.
So I was also thinking like,
producing content on English,
I started new accounts, but
it didn't work out because
it's too complicated
to reach other regions
Thank you Isaiah
and all of that,
- I think, switching back and forth
between English and Spanish
on your 1.7 is not a bad idea.
The English will do worse,
but over time it will build.
And then some content can be in Spanglish.
I always tell a lot of my
Spanish-speaking friends.
Make one account, some of it's in Spanish,
some of it's in English,
some of it's in Spanglish.
I mean, you might be the way
people learn how to speak
English that speak Spanish.
You know, it's a lot, I mean,
there's unlimited people
that speak both languages.
And you have to be...
Let's go Walstar, finally.
And if you, as long as you
don't worry about the metrics
and you're okay with your
Spanish content getting,
800,000 views or 80,000 views.
- It just froze.
- Who I froze?
I can hear you, can you hear me?
- Yeah.
- Don't worry that the English content
is not gonna be doing as well.
Thank you Extended family.
Don't worry that the English
content won't do as well.
- Yeah, I'm not worried about that,
but I'm just worried that it won't
even reach all the regions
because of the regional locking
you know, it's really complicated.
- You don't control that, bro.
- Yeah.
- You can't cry about shit
that you don't control.
- Yeah.
- Period.
- So do you think going for the ask that
it's better on TikTok,
rather than LinkedIn or stuff like that?
- No, both.
- No, both?
- I'm sorry, Nicole.
Both.
- Okay
Keep moving Alex.
You're gonna win.
You got this, bro, I feel
real good about your vibes.
Talk to you soon.
Let's keep moving it.
- Okay, bye.
- Youngsters.
Dustin, I'm not getting
comments, all live comments,
so please throw up a
bunch during the episode
'cause I live off that shit.
- Roger.
- Thank you.
Michael what's good?
Hi Gary.
- How are you bro?
- Good.
What's cooking?
How're you?
Not much.
I'm supper well.
- So I was wondering if
our parents don't approve
of social medias like
TikTok and Instagram,
how can we convince them
that it can be a great thing.
- One more time, brother,
- If our parents don't
approve of social media,
how can we convince them that
it can be a great thing for
like fun, meeting new friends,
and if we have a business,
we can promote our business.
- You know convincing parents
when you're a kid is super hard.
- Yeah.
- You know, I think one of the
ways to do that is results,
like take that bowling ball pin
and sell it for $40 on TikTok
and then show them that.
And all of a sudden they
may take it more serious.
Why do your parents demonize social?
They think it's a good,
it's a waste of time?
They think...
- I think mostly they
think it's a waste of time,
but they let me have it,
I kind of convinced them.
But, a lot of my friends I know,
they want social media, but
their parents won't let them.
- Look, parents normally parent with fear.
So they're worried their
kid's gonna get in trouble,
see something they don't want to,
get influenced by somebody bad.
The reality is that's a historic game.
That's not Tea with GaryVee
is gonna answer this question.
Meaning, it's crazy Michael how that is.
That's been the story of time.
Your parents tried to
convince their parents
that playing video games
or listening to rock
albums was a good idea.
And your grandparents
were trying to convince
your great grandparents
that listening to Elvis and
the Beatles was a good...
It's all the same shit,
you know what I mean?
- Yeah.
- The reality is that all you can do
is try to find the balance
of really, really...
Thank you Dustin, for
putting up Anthony Conti
Hey Conti,
when you can explain to me
what bullshit I'm selling,
we can have that talk.
I really think that you
just have to balance
the family dynamic with
trying to do a little bit
of your own when they're 'not watching'
and number two, try to show
a positive result from it
so that it 'changes your parent's mind.'
But half the parents in the
world never change their mind
and are so selfish about
how they see the world.
They don't become selfless
enough to help their children
fulfill the way they see the world.
- Yeah, that's kind of
what I'm doing right now.
- I love that.
You watch my content?
- Yeah, I do.
- You like it?
- You're showing up on
TikTok a lot more now.
- Trying bro, hustling out here.
What part of the content most
resonates for you, Michael?
- I try to make like funny content.
- I like that.
Are you part of the us crash gang?
- Yeah.
- I love that.
It's good bro.
Bro, just keep going.
I think parents is always a tricky game,
but always remember eventually
you're moving out of the house
and you gotta live for your happiness
without being disrespectful to parents.
That's what I'd tell your buddies.
- Yeah.
- You know, they eventually
they're not gonna live there
and they're gonna have
to live the next 80 years
of their life on their own.
And they have to find a balance
of doing what they want,
while respecting and emp...
It's hard for 15, 13, 12 year old
to be empathetic to their parents,
but parents are always doing that shit
because they're scared.
- Yeah.
- So try to unscare them.
- Okay.
- Cool, talk to you soon.
- Thanks.
- Of course, Michael.
Dustin get that guy
who called me a bullshit
artist on the show.
(laughs)
We can have a real conversation.
I'd like him to articulate
in detail, my bullshit.
- That would be interesting.
- Yeah, I've had so many of
those conversations in my life.
Like people come into my office,
I've done a lot of weird stuff like that
and just the shit that people make up.
They're like, you're selling
out, like, what am I selling?
Tough to sell something worth
of dollars and zero cents.
"You're giving people too much hope."
Literally this is what
one guy told me Dustin.
Gary you're a fucking bullshit artists
'cause you're giving
people fucking false hope.
I'm like, bro, don't take
your cynicism on the world
and fucking deploy.
"I'm just keeping it real."
I'm like, "You're keeping it
real fucking sad and dark."
Keeping it real, fuck you.
There's unlimited
opportunity motherfucker.
- Yeah.
- Let's keep it going.
- You're on mute Cosmin.
- Cosmin you're on mute.
- Hi, how are you?
Sorry.
- Very well, what's your name?
- I'm Cosmin.
- Cosmin, where are you from?
- I'm from Italy, I think
you remember you did a live.
- I do, I remember.
I'm doing it for them Cosmin.
what's cooking, what can I answer for you?
- So my question comes
from an interview you did
with Draw with Jazza if you
remember, about artists,
and you said there should be a balance
of both selling your
work, like your own work
and working for others.
But how do you get to a place where
you only have to sell your work?
So we don't work on Fiverr
and stuff like that.
- How do you get to a
place where, what brother?
- Like you can only sell your work,
like you don't have to work on Fiverr.
- I mean, there's a lot of
people who never get there.
It's called talent and hard work.
You know what I mean?
- Yeah, I get.
- And, Dustin put on Anthony.
Cosmin you've gotta
put in hard work
and you've got to get to a place
where you work hard
and there's a demand for your stuff.
- So it's like more of a brand thing than,
it's more of a building
your own brand than,
- Of course, of course,
you know, simple as that.
- Yeah I get it.
- I see it Dustin, I see
the anger, the negativity,
you can get them in here,
you don't need to flash it anymore Dustin.
Yeah Cosmin, it's really just
hard work and brand building
and you know, then it comes to you.
Got it?
- Yeah, I was thinking about,
like I'm not yet on TikTok,
but maybe start posting there
and like showing the process.
- Of course, you know the answers,
I'm putting it out every day.
- Yeah, I get it.
- It's awesome, keep pushing
Cos, talk to you soon, bro.
- Thank you.
- You got it.
Hi.
Kenzie, how are you?
- How're you?
- Good, how are you?
- It's such a pleasure.
- I'm from Michigan, and I've been golfing
for like 11 years now.
- Wow.
- And my goal was
originally to make varsity
for my high school freshman year,
which I did that this year.
- Congratulations.
- Thank you.
But now I wanna like take it further
and play for like a D1 college,
which I know you're not like
the biggest fan of college
but...
- Listen Kenzie, real quick,
and I'll use this opportunity.
I'm a huge fan of college
for people that don't
go into massive debt,
and then in four years have a diploma
that doesn't give them
leverage in the new workforce.
And then, I get hundreds of
thousands of emails and DMS
and messages from kids
that are really bad shape
because they were sold a dream
that doesn't have a reality.
If you go to a D1 school
and get a scholarship,
I'm all about that life.
- Right, yeah, that's the
goal, that's the dream.
So what I'm really wondering
is I know I'm not there yet
like skill level and
I'm working to get there
along with like my grades,
but I was wondering if you
had any like suggestions
for my next step or like how
to get noticed in the future.
- I mean, I think you
put out content, right?
- Right
- You know, because I'm in Vayner sports,
tons of kids are going
to D1 football colleges
from small towns that would
have never been discovered,
because they're putting up
their highlights on Twitter,
on YouTube, on Facebook, on Instagram,
you should put out your
golf highlights everywhere.
- Right.
- You know, there's gonna be
a D1 coach that's gonna see it
and be like, "Yo, go check on
that Kenzie girl in Michigan.
- Right, yeah, that's a good idea.
- That's how.
No different than Cosmin, the last call,
it's all about getting awareness.
- Right, so for doing that,
would you suggest like
making its own account,
just for golf or just
putting it all over (mumbles)
- I like normal, but you
may not wanna do that
with your social life and
I would understand that.
- Right.
- You know?
- Yeah.
Just because with school, I
know I shouldn't really care,
but it is hard sometimes,
a lot of people will hate
because I do golf and
they'll say it's not a sport.
- Yeah, I mean, honestly, now
you make me want to tell you
to put it into your regular account
because the quicker you get over the hump
of giving a fuck when the cute guy says,
it's not a score and you're sad,
the quicker you like the girl
you want to be friends with.
You know what I mean?
The quicker you get over that hump,
the happier your whole life will be.
- Right, for sure.
- For real.
- Yeah.
- For real Kenz.
- Yeah, I do put, I have like a highlight
on my Instagram with all my golf stuff,
- But you need to put
out a lot of content,
maybe use Twitter for that.
- Right.
- Are you active on Twitter?
- I'm not, I don't have Twitter.
- Good, perfect, so get a Twitter
and go ham on there because
that's where a lot of coaches
recruit from that platform.
- Okay.
- All right?
- Awesome.
- Good luck.
- Thank you so much, it
was awesome talking to you.
- Thank you so much, take care.
- Have a good one.
- You too Kenz.
Kai what's good?
- Hey Gary, yo, I'm so
grateful to be here.
- It's good to have you bro
- How you doing?
- I'm doing too well, what's
cooking, what's your question?
- That's great.
So basically my name's Kai,
I'm 15 years old and from South Africa
and I've had quite a unique upbringing.
At around the age of eight,
my parents decided to sell their cause
rent off the house and
go on a sort of like
spiritual journey
traveling around the world
for a couple years.
And this really sparked
a huge interest for me
in entrepreneurship, because
I would visit so many,
villages and different
cultures and so many countries.
And I would always notice,
how different everything was,
wherever you go and how the
culture of selling and buying
and negotiating is, completely
varies wherever you are.
And I mean, from the youngest
age, in India for example,
I would go to the beach at
eight years old and I would,
volunteer at these restaurants
and I would learn how to do magic tricks
and I'd do it on the beach with tourists,
get as many tips as I can, save it all.
You know, every week when I was in Bali,
I would get my hands on anything I could
at the cheap markets
and then go to the more
upper-class ones and sell it there.
And yeah, so I mean when
I got back to South Africa
for high school, I've my time and my,
I kind of I've been focusing more on that.
And actually, yeah, I
competed in my country,
it's called the Allan Gray
Entrepreneurship Challenge.
So in 2018 I came in the
top 20 in South Africa
- Good for you.
in the six week competition.
And then the next year I actually
managed to get top three.
- Wow.
- So I won, it was an
international trip to Marina Bay
in Singapore, for a tech conference.
It was gonna happen this year,
unfortunately it got postponed,
but I mean that was really cool.
So I mean, my whole life
I've been absolutely obsessed
with everything to do with it.
And I really, really love this.
And I mean, about five, six months ago,
I started really pushing on TikTok,
I built, I mean, and
I know it's not a lot,
but I built about 140,000
followers on there.
And it's all because of you,
so I'm very grateful about that.
- All because of you, you executed.
I've told a lot of people to do it.
You executed.
- Yeah, thank you, man.
I appreciate it.
- What can I answer for you?
- So my ultimate question would be,
how do I take this, huge
passion that I have for business
and combine that with an online presence.
- By communicating.
I don't think you realize you've already.
Bro you're 15 you said,
- Yeah.
- Bro you already have a
real audience on TikTok,
just keep baking.
- Okay.
- You've already done it.
The thing, your ultimate
question that you had for me,
you've already executed.
- Yeah.
- I mean...
- Yeah, yeah, okay I understand.
- You see where I'm going?
- Yeah.
- Like, you're at 140 now ,when
you're old as fuck like me,
I'm young, by the way, when you're 44,
that number is gonna be enormous.
- Yeah, that's the goal
- Bro, listen to me,
you're gonna live two more
full lives from the day
you were born to right now.
You're going to do that two more times
and you'll be my age.
Think about how much time you have.
- Yeah, okay, I understand.
'Cause I mean like, what I was
also thinking to ask you is,
'cause like right now I'm
in high school, you know?
And there's a lot of stress,
like a lot of family pushing on,
but I'm not particularly
enjoying it that much.
I do put a lot of effort into
it, but you know, it's tough.
- Who is pushing you?
Your parents?
- Like all my grandparents.
- Well tell your grandparents,
your fucking parents flew
around the fucking world
on a whim.
How the fuck were you supposed
to give a fuck about school?
Tell your grandparents to
talk to their fucking kids.
They fucking flew you
around the fucking world.
What the fuck were you?
You were fucking on the beach
in India when you were eight.
How the fuck do you...
You know, come on.
(laughs)
- I mean, my whole family is
actually also from the Jews,
from the Soviet union.
So a lot of them are like
very, you know how it is.
- Of course I do.
- Yeah, so I mean, I guess
my other question would be,
considering my personal situation,
what do you think is the most
promising industry to go into,
in the next three to five years?
Like what should I pursue?
- Social, cannabis,
cryptocurrency, blockchain, voice,
bro, a million things.
Bro, you have all the right mindset,
you have all the right ingredients.
You're fucking set.
Don't beat yourself up, stay patient,
be nice and kind, don't,
My friend, listen to me.
There's two ways to build
the biggest building Kai,
one just build the biggest building.
Two, tear down everybody else's building.
Be the first one.
Don't worry about other people's success.
It doesn't come from you, stay
patient, stay humble, work,
you've got all the fucking ingredients.
You're well on your way.
- Thank you so much
man, means a whole lot.
- Talk to you soon.
- I'd love to keep in
contact with you soon, man.
- Well, I'd love that.
All right.
Let's get some more in here.
- Gary, what's up?
- What's good Rachel.
- Oh man, this is cool.
So a quick little story.
I'm from Brooklyn, New York, 19 years old.
I'm gonna be starting college this fall.
- Congrats.
- And I'm essentially YouTuber
and I've built up a small
audience of almost 7,000 on there,
- Fantastic.
- But my thing that I struggled with,
is there are times where
I'm like super consistent
with my content posting every week,
and there are times where I go like
two weeks without posting and is because
- Perfect.
- Every time I put my
focus into the video,
I want it to be as good as possible.
So my question is essentially,
how do I like overcome perfectionism.
- By forcing yourself to do
things that are uncomfortable.
So what I mean by that is,
the next time you see a video
and you're like, I gotta
keep working on this,
remember this moment and just post it
because one of those videos
is gonna do better than
all the other ones that you perfected.
And that will teach
you the fucking lesson.
- You're right, you're right.
But there are even times where
I'm in that mindset, right?
And then I post the
video and then it's like,
Oh man, it could have been better.
Or you know, maybe I should
have waited a little more
and worked on this like that.
- That's because you're
beating yourself up.
Perfection is hiding insecurity.
- That's true.
You're right, I mean, yeah.
- You just have to practice.
It's like working out.
It's like eating, like Kerry,
how do I eat better so I get healthier?
Eat better.
- Yeah.
- Well, how?
Fight your head and get into
a place where you just do.
- Yeah.
- The fact that you're
even asking the question
means that you're,
the subconscious of it
has become conscious
and now you have a real shot.
- Yeah, yeah, I have
people constantly asking me
upload more, upload more
and it's like, I want to,
and whenever I don't, I feel
like I disappointed people,
you know?
- Listen, you need to
worry about yourself,
go into your own place, but
you need to love yourself.
- You're right.
- You know, I'm just telling you,
if people are asking you upload more,
people enjoy it, but more importantly,
you need to enjoy the process,
not the subscribers or the views.
- Yeah, no I do.
I love the process.
I wouldn't trade it for anything.
- Well then great, so
then put out more shit.
- All right, I will.
- I believe you.
- I'm just gonna do it, Thank you.
- Good luck.
- I appreciate coming on here.
- Of course Rach.
- Thank you.
Nice chatting to you Gary.
- Of course, take care.
Rachel's YouTube right
there for everybody.
Let's keep it moving.
Let's take a couple more kids in.
Fun show.
- Yo, Gary.
- What's good, Noah?
- Whats good.
So just a little story.
I am a 15 year old from like
the smallest town in Ohio.
- I love it.
- It's like the smallest, very Southern
right across from West Virginia.
So yeah and I wanna be a YouTuber.
- Okay.
- So like, I have been posting on TikTok,
but like it's just not
going anywhere with TikTok,
so is that like bad?
- No, it's not bad, but good news Noah,
YouTube's even harder to grow than TikTok.
- Yeah, I know.
But so I guess my question...
- How many posts on TikTok?
- I have like 30 right now.
- Okay, keep going.
- So I guess my question is,
is it okay to target like
two audiences at once?
- 100%.
- I was gonna do like gaming
and blogs, I can do that?
- Yes.
100%
- All right.
'Cause I see like other things like,
you should only go after one audience.
- No.
- But I didn't.
- No, people say that
because they want you
to win the short term game.
You may get more subscribers
and views if you target one,
but you're fucking 15
and you need to figure out
who you are and what you like.
And I'd rather you learn that
and have half as many
followers and subscribers
and you still might have more subscribers.
People play checkers.
I'm trying to play chess
out here with you, Noah.
You're 15, we're just starting.
I want you to do an entire account
just on your fucking dimples,
it's your biggest strength.
I got 'em too bro.
- Totally makes sense.
- Yeah, bro, just do a whole,
make all your TikTok about
your fucking dimples.
Make 10 fucking TikToks
about your dimples.
- All right, I will.
- I'm serious.
- And when all your buddies
are like 'That's corny,"
tell 'em to fucking come to me
and I'm gonna punch them
in the fucking face.
- All right, I will.
- Good bro.
- I'll come show him this shame.
- All right bro, talk, go ahead
- Other than that, do you
just have any advice for like
a starting YouTuber?
- Yeah, to just fucking make
and not look at numbers.
Numbers will fuck you up.
Same with TikTok bro.
I want you to make much more TikTok,
just do random different shit
and look at trending topics and hashtags
and try to make your version of that.
- All right.
- Got it?
- Yeah, perfect.
- I want you to lean into TikTok.
It's much more free
awareness than YouTube.
Take care bro, we got you.
- That's it, I think we
got you here saying TikTok.
- Thank you bro, talk to you soon.
- See ya.
- Let's keep this going.
Let's sneak another one in.
- Hi Gary.
- Hi Briana.
- I just want to start with that
I'm really excited to be here,
it's like awesome opportunity.
- Thank you.
- So just wanna thank you for that first.
- You're welcome.
- So I'm 17, I'm from
Long Island, New York.
So chilled background before
I go into my question.
So I have a passion,
I've developed over the course of my life.
Many passions and inside,
but two specific ones
being film and sports.
And I've always dreamed
of possibly going into
either industry whether
it be a film editor
or in sports a GM or a financial advisor,
a sports writer, anything like that.
I never allowed myself to
go after any of those dreams
because I've always worried about job
and financial security
from a really young age.
So I was always worried that
if I followed these passions,
I would risk like this
dream lifestyle I have,
which is like, a comfortable lifestyle,
making enough money to be comfortable.
So especially with being a
girl in the sports industry,
I felt like, it'd be just
too hard to get a good job,
and good money.
So instead I really focused on school
and discovering jobs that you know,
where I would be have a secure
job and make good money.
But this past summer I took
a sports statistics course
and I was really a huge
fan of a course itself
through various field
trips, to like sports places
and stuff like that.
I figured I really do
wanna go into this industry
as like a manager, writer, anything I can.
So I feel like I can't follow that dream
because I still have
those old fears of job,
- Makes sense.
- and financial security now.
So my question is do I bother?
- Did your parents instill that,
like be safe, have a roof over your head
or was that just in your natural DNA?
- I think it's more natural
because my parents are really supportive
of anything I really wanna do.
- I love that.
- Yeah, my mom has always been like,
follow your dream sort of thing so.
- Listen to me, wouldn't it be like,
if I said to you, Hey, imagine
living with your best friends
all the time.
That's good?
That's like fun?
- Yeah.
- Good.
So let me explain this to you.
If you follow your dreams,
you'll have to live with like
three of your best girlfriends
or boyfriends or whoever like your friends
in one house and eat like ramen
and like fucking live that life.
That's more fun.
- Yeah.
- It's more fun to try to be on MSG
or to be a general manager or something,
it's like more fun, it makes you happier.
Like you can worry about a
fucking roof over your head
and a white picket fence
and a fucking nice car
when you're 37.
You're fucking 17.
Like the next seven years
you can go follow your dream.
This is the time to actually
be risky, not be safe.
- Okay. Yeah.
- Does that make like that's a lot,
like you're being logical, which I love.
So be logical.
In your twenties is
when you can take risk.
To me I think it's more
fun to try to be on SNY,
and live in like Queens
with four of your friends
in a shitty spot and going out at night
and having fun and
following all your dreams,
than it is for you to have some secure job
and take a 40 minute
train ride into the city
from fucking Long Island
on some fucking townhouse.
- Yes, you're right, 100%.
You know, I've always had these fears,
I guess they're also
holding me back in a way.
- In a way?
They're completely
fucking holding you back
from being happy.
- Yeah.
- What are you scared of?
Let's talk about it.
Like what are you scared of?
You're scared of like
living in a shitty place?
I don't get it.
- I mean, yeah, I was fortunate enough to,
I'm living in long Island
and in a great town too.
- Great.
- So I'm used to this lifestyle, you know?
That's not something I wanna lose either
because I feel like I got too comfortable.
- I don't think you realize
how little you want that lifestyle.
You haven't tasted the alternative.
When you live in a
shithole with your buddies,
when you're in your twenties,
but you're living your best life
'cause you're going
after your fucking dream,
that's gonna taste a lot
better than a big room
and a nice fucking yard.
- Yeah, you're right.
I'm also just not sure,
like as a girl especially,
how do even get into this industry?
- What are you talking about?
There's like half of the sports casters,
there are so many women in sports.
- I mean like management positions though,
like doing things like, I don't know.
- Managing a team?
- Yeah, something like that, you know?
- Yes, that's less.
There's coaches starting to emerge,
there's NFL coaches.
We're starting to see it.
And by the time you're 34,
when it'll be realistic,
there's probably gonna be a lot more.
It's not 1965 anymore.
There's unlimited women in sport.
- True, yeah.
- Plus once you go in for management,
you might realize you wanna be a scout,
and there's unlimited women in scout.
You might realize you wanna
be a journalist for it,
there's unlimited...
You might decide you wanna
start a social media company
to represent athletes.
You might wanna compete
with Vayner sports.
You don't know yet.
- Yeah.
- But don't take some bullshit job
because you want a fucking
bush outside your house.
- Yeah, yeah, right.
- You're not as accustomed
to your cushy as you think.
- Okay.
- I mean that, you're not.
You have to get comfortable with fear.
- Okay, yeah, okay.
- It's more fun.
- It's more fun, you will like it more.
And by the way, my prescription for you
is to actually live in a shitty situation.
I want you to live in the hood in Queens.
Like I'm serious.
- Okay.
'Cause then, you'll know you can.
You have to make yourself uncomfortable.
- Yeah, okay, I understand.
- Good, good luck.
- Thank you so much.
- You're welcome so
much Briana, take care.
Bye bye.
Thank you.
- All right everybody,
thank you so much for watching the show.
Big WineText today.
Thank you for all the kids.
How many kids do we
have in the queue, Dust?
- Two.
- All right, we'll
sneak them in next week.
Thank you.
It's good to be back on the Tea show.
Let's leave some #teawithgaryvee,
thoughts on today's show please on Twitter
so I can watch on next boring meeting.
It's not boring, but it's operational.
And I love you guys,
I love the youngsters.
I love the hate in
today's episode as well.
And big shout out to "Boat",
Lil Yachty's new album has dropped.
Please check it out.
And honestly you need some white wine,
today's is a banger!
A banger!
We'll see you next time
on Tea with Garyvee.
Check out my new Twitter handle,
GaryVee TV, it is exploding.
Sign up right now, here's why you should.
- The people that are gonna win
over the next five to seven years,
are going to be very comfortable
in controlled fucking chaos.
You don't love the process.
This is who we're talking about.
Dreams require sacrifice.
All of your actions have
to then match to it.
Backpack, pack, pack, pack time.
Nobody gives a shit
about where you grew up.
The whole game is scaling the unscalable.
It's fucking hard work,
it's being respectful,
it's being a good person,
do that, that's just a good idea.
It's there, the flipping's there.
This house right here, there's $400 in it.
I stay in my lane, like
real fucking tight,
but you can't be crippled.
Everybody who is judging themselves.
You're looking at what's
in front of you right now.
You're losing 'cause
you're laying in your bed,
looking at somebody's fucking glamorous,
photo-shopped picture of
them doing something cool.
And you're envious and you're
jealous and you're impatient.
And it's crippling your upside.
Let me just say it one more time
if you're confused what I just said.
I say, put your fucking flag on the ground
of who the fuck you are,
whoever provides the
most value, always wins.
You're entering the greatest
five year window of your life.
My only answer to Nate
or anybody is just like,
try shit, put your business down
and go work for an apparel
company for two years.
Nobody you've ever met got
there without the hard work.
So you better get your speed
up, you better work harder,
you better work smarter.
If you can't google stuff,
you're not gonna be able to do anything
that I'm telling you here.
GARYVEETV, my new account, check me out.
Hope you enjoy it.